bueno en esta ocasión me quiero tomar la
siguiente integral me voy a tomar la
integral de 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de
3 - 2x cuadrada y esto por diferencial
de x y bueno como resuelvo esta integral
lo primero que se me podría ocurrir es
intentar hacerla por una sustitución 1
sin embargo intentar hacerla por la
sustitución no es nada trivial entonces
cuando yo veo este tipo de integrales y
más si son del caso de algo menos algo x
x al cuadrado raíz esto es un buen
sinónimo de que se me ocurra usar una
sustitución trigonométricas entonces lo
que voy a hacer es resolver esta
integral por sustitución trigonométricas
y cómo resuelvo eso bueno lo primero que
tengo que tomar en cuenta es la
identidad de econométrica más importante
que existe que dice que el seno al
cuadrado más el corte en al cuadrado es
lo mismo que 1 y si de esta ecuación yo
restó el seno cuadrado de ambos lados
que me va a quedar bueno puede restar el
seno o el coseno cuadrado
casi siempre se usa a restar el seno
cuadrado entonces me queda que el
concepto cuadrado de teta es lo mismo
que uno menos el seno cuadrado de teta y
bueno esto para que porque yo lo que
quiero ver es que esto que está dentro
de la raíz se parezca un poco a uno
menos el seno cuadrado de teta y se dan
cuenta lo primero que tendría que hacer
es quitar este 3 de aquí por lo tanto es
lo que voy a hacer voy a decir que esto
es lo mismo que la integral de 1 entre
la raíz y voy a factorizar un 3 no voy a
hacer nada raro nada del otro mundo lo
que hace es factorizar un 3 y me queda 3
que multiplica a uno menos dos tercios
de x cuadrada y todo esto que multiplica
a la diferencial de x y bueno ya empieza
a tomar un poquito más de forma ahora lo
que quiero es que uno menos dos tercios
de x cuadradas es lo mismo que uno menos
seno cuadrado de teta o dicho de otra
manera lo único que me hace falta es que
los dos tercios de x cuadradas sean lo
mismo que el seno cuadrado de teta por
lo tanto lo voy a escribir acá abajo lo
que yo quiero es que dos tercios de x
sean igual al seno cuadrado de teta sea
igual al seno cuadrado de teta y lo
primero que voy a hacer es tomar la raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados entonces me
queda que la raíz cuadrada de 2 sobre la
raíz cuadrada de 3 que multiplica a x es
lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada del seno
cuadrado de teta es decir el seno de
teta y ahora lo que se me ocurre hacer
es despejar en esta ecuación a x de
hecho necesita despejar a x y también a
teta entonces voy a hacer las dos
despejes de una vez primero voy a
despejar la teta
entonces me queda que teta es igual a la
función inversa del seno que es el arco
cuyo seno de la raíz de 2 entre la raíz
de 3 que multiplica a x esto para
despejar la teta pero por otro lado
también necesito despejar a x entonces
para despejar a x lo que tengo que hacer
es tomar el inverso de raíz de dos entre
raíz de tres y pasarlo del otro lado es
decir me va a quedar que x es igual a la
raíz de tres entre raíz de dos que
multiplica al seno de teta que
multiplica al seno de teta y estoy
haciendo todo esto porque aquí ya tengo
despejada x por lo tanto puedo sustituir
la línea
original pero antes de ir a substituir
lo que voy a sacar es la derivada de x
con respecto a teta entonces me queda
que la derivada de x con respecto a teta
es lo mismo que la raíz de 3 entre la
raíz de dos son constantes que
multiplica a la derivada del seno de
teta es decir el coste de 9 teta y bueno
esto visto en su forma diferencial
implica que la diferencia del de x es lo
mismo que la raíz de 3 entre la raíz de
todos que multiplica al coste no
detentan diferencial de teta y todo esto
porque lo estoy haciendo porque ahora
voy a hacer mi cambio de variable y voy
a sustituir todo en integral así que
tomemos el color rojizo o mejor el color
azulado eso es lo mismo que bueno bueno
esperen 1 que multiplica a de x pues es
lo mismo que tener de x entonces en
lugar de poner aquí 1 voy a poner arriba
de x y voy a cancelar este x que yo
tengo aquí y ahora sí voy a sustituir
arriba me queda de x pero la diferencial
de x es lo mismo que la raíz de 3 entre
la raíz de 2 por el coste no detecta
diferencial de teta entonces lo voy a
escribir aquí me queda la integral es la
raíz de 3
a raíz de 2 que multiplica a su vez algo
que no detecta todo esto por diferencial
de teta y lo único que hice fue
sustituir a la diferencial de x y a todo
esto lo tenemos que dividir entre la
raíz de quien entre la raíz de 3 que
multiplica a uno menos dos tercios de x
cuadrada pero dos tercios de x cuadrada
es el seno cuadrado de teta menos el
seno cuadrado de teta y ya está ahora
bien se cuenta que uno menos el seno
cuadrado de teta es justo lo que
habíamos sacado en un principio esto de
aquí es lo mismo que el cruce no
cuadrado de t está usando la identidad
pitagórica entonces esto me queda de la
siguiente manera esa integral de raíz de
3 / raíz de 2 que multiplica al coste no
detecta diferencial de teta y todo esto
dividido entre la raíz de 3 la raíz de 3
que multiplica al coseno cuadrado de
teta y todo eso para que aquí hay muchos
conceptos y raíces pero lo que puedo
simplificar es lo que está en él
esto es lo mismo que la integral de raíz
de 3 / raíz de 2 ahora con color verde
raíz de tres en tres dedos por el coche
no detectan diferencial de teta entre y
aquí tengo la raíz de 3 que multiplica
con sumo cuadrado pues esto es lo mismo
que la raíz de 3 que multiplica a la
raíz del coste no cuadrado es decir el
coseno de teta y aquí ya puedo
simplificar varias cosas por ejemplo
quitaron coseno que multiplica y coseno
que dividen se van a raíz de 3 que está
arriba y reyes de 3 que está abajo
también se van y entonces todo esto me
queda simple y sencillamente la integral
de 1 entre la raíz de 2 por la
diferencial de teta y bueno aquí voy a
bajar un poco la pantalla y voy a usar
una propiedad integral que dice que
podemos sacar las constantes entonces
esto es lo mismo que 1 entre la raíz de
2 que multiplica a la integral de
detectar pero el integral de 30 es una
integral bien sencilla de resolver es lo
mismo que 1 entre la raíz de todos que
multiplica a teta más una constante de
integración y bueno podrías decir que
esto es lo mismo que uno sobre veis de
dos que multiplica una constante por el
final pues es una constante arbitraria
entonces tengo uno entre
de 2 que multiplica más una constante de
integración y hemos acabado bueno no
hemos acabado esperen falta sustituir a
theta en términos de x porque nuestra
integral original estaba en términos de
x pero ya tenemos aquí despejada teta
para eso nos sirvió por lo tanto esto es
lo mismo que 1 entre la raíz de 2 aquí
está esta integral que tenemos aquí
nuestra integral original ya tenemos una
solución en términos de x es 1 sobre la
raíz de 2 que multiplica al arco seno de
raíz de dos sobre raíz de 3x al arco
seno de la raíz de 2 entre la raíz de 3
por x ya esto hay que aumentarle nuestra
constante de integración y hemos acabado
logramos sacar la integral de 1 entre la
raíz de tres menos 2x cuadrada
diferencial de x utilizando la
sustitución trigonométricas y voy a
hacer varios vídeos más sobre este tipo
de sustitución para que te familiarices
más con ello porque este tipo de
sustitución es muy útil para resolver
integrales así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo